30 jefes de estado y de gobierno 50
ministros de exteriores 25 ministros de
defensa todos reunidos este fin de
semana en un lujoso hotel de la ciudad
de munich en el sur de alemania para lo
que es sin duda una de las citas anuales
más importantes en la política
internacional la conferencia de
seguridad de múnich este año incluso más
relevante e incluso más urgente por las
actuales tensiones que existen entre
rusia y ucrania de que haya muchísimo
interés por la participación de algunos
de los invitados más importantes como
kamala harris la vicepresidenta de eeuu
o volodymyr silencia el presidente de
ucrania walk of souls el canciller
alemán también se espera la
participación del primer ministro
británico boris johnson o el secretario
general de naciones unidas antonio
guterres
un bemol un punto crítico de esta
conferencia de seguridad este año la
ausencia de altos funcionarios de rusia
lo que podría dificultar negociaciones y
discusiones que normalmente se
desarrollan también al margen de la
conferencia principal